was that abba you were playing
abba yes it was
how do you pronounce it
are you in pain i think i think i think
it's just abba it was so weird you went
ah
that's the way that that's why what
porpoise would say it if scientists
worked on it for like a year
i did work on it good porpoise good says
george c
scott all right abba abba
abba what are you max weinberg i i i
think i have it
all right keep working on it abba just
abba that's what the kids are listening
to now i'm in touch
all right the two of us arguing over the
pronunciation of abba
that's a good you stop doing that
it's working people just tuning in have
never seen the show will be like isn't
that nice a learning disabled man is on
the drum
isn't that nice just the guy in the
drummer's over there
how was your day max
hubba you will eventually start saying
something else
and the doctors will be most pleased all
right i want to talk to you
this is uh i did something cool recently
um there's
there's apparently there's a deli here
in new york city
that's called the stage delhi and
probably a lot of you have probably
heard of it it's a big new york city
landmark
it's pretty famous and the stage deli
will they name
sandwiches after celebrities at this
place
and about two weeks ago i heard that
they honored me
so uh i was excited so just the other
day just
like two days ago i grabbed a camera
crew and i went over there to check it
out
and uh well this is what we found
this is the stage delicatessen it's a
new york city landmark
they named sandwiches after celebrities
here and i understand they named
something after me
it's pretty exciting
these sandwiches make no sense look at
this the gloria estefan
tuna bacon american cheese lettuce and
tomato
really captures her native cuba
look at this jack wagner hot open turkey
that's a really good sandwich
what the hell is jack wagner excuse me
sir do you know who jack wagner is no
idea
here's the halle berry salami
tongue and pastrami
i guess that makes sense i don't know
her
john stamos greek salad john stamos his
show's been off the air for
eight years is it just because he's the
only greek person they could come up
with
look richard simmons tropical fruit
salad
and then look way down here at the
bottom
conan o'brien soup and salad
choice of any soup and a small house
salad this is incredibly depressing how
many people
order the conan o'brien soup and salad
oh about three four five
a day so it's not really popular not the
greatest thing in the world
i'm the king of late night what am i
doing not the king don't get excited not
the king of late night
maybe late late late night but not late
there's two guys
way ahead of yourself yeah
what are you going to do you want to get
rid of them yes
get rid of them show them how did you
think about getting the conan o'brien
which is a soup and salad
uh no i really did i would order it just
for the fact that
i think you're a nice person thank you
that was a nice
you took pity on me thank you very much
what time do you get off
when are you done with work
oh she laughed i always leave during
that part
this is exciting uh we're gonna go visit
the woman who ordered the conan o'brien
sharon um you just ordered the conan
o'brien
that's that's pretty exciting did you
order it because you were excited about
conan o'brien
absolutely you have no idea who i am do
you you're absolutely right
you've never seen me before have you no
do you stay up late often no and i don't
watch tv
you don't watch tv at all this must be
thrilling for you to meet me
why don't you have a taste right now and
we'll see how you have it dribble down
my chin on tv or something no
come on you think we'd do something like
that please dribble please
think you have to improve your image by
a sandwich you got to be a corby
pastrami combo
with a little brisket that would be a
great sandwich actually that's it that's
you
say it again cornbread beef pay
attention so you're listening
i'm sorry i've been drinking all right
pastrami that's an amazing one sandwich
please don't interrupt
hey norman yes sir would you please yes
this is it tell me what this is this is
uh the future conan o'brien sandwich
this is you sir okay where is the
mayonnaise and the m m's
there's no mayonnaise and peanut m m's
just pushed in there
like i told you not in arkansas you're
not in wyoming you're in new york city
little caramel how about little dribble
little caramel absolutely zero
listen this is you one suggestion i'm
gonna say one thing and then i'll be
quiet
don't you better be quiet and don't say
nothing cake frosting
i i just told you before don't say
nothing put a little cake chocolate cake
you're wasting your energy
this is you this is the new conan
o'brien this
is a sandwich
[Applause]
oh my god that's my thumb
i almost ate my thumb so it
looks like i'm sort of moving up um i'm
gonna get a sandwich of my own
they're gonna design so either way i'm
sort of headed to the big time
and uh i was wondering if you would
take over my soup and salad
for me
or not
[Applause]
that's my new sandwich that's a great
sandwich
i love that sandwich all right we'll
take a little break big show tonight we
come back brendan fraser going to join
us